I think that once I felt that script was
right and that story was my story and
actually my story with my feelings with
my I mean my father had when I was
growing up my father had this you know
he always pushed me harder and and do
better and and more and more and more
and even if you came home thank you but
with an a-plus you know you could you
better you know you could do better I
know you could and I felt like where
does it stop you know how how much
further do I go what you know what do I
have to do to prove you know but I
always found myself and one day I
stopped and I was honest and I said you
it's you feeling like you have to prove
just someone else that you are good
enough or you are better or you're you
know the best so at that point I felt
yeah it's it's time I think there's
things that they didn't know if the
whole world just I believe felt that I
grew up with this grandiose you know
life of luxury and and wine and roses
when it was anything but that so I just
felt the need that you know I felt my
kids were old enough now there's no more
you know wouldn't never lie to them but
there were things that just weren't
addressed weren't talked about weren't
discussed and then at a certain point I
mean now we're like best friends they're
young men you know so we talk about
everything and this was the time so
because there's so much fascination with
your life and people haven't you know
read your novels with this film do you
feel like that in particular is what
they're gonna learn new from this film
because like what are people gonna learn
new and I know you're saying yeah people
had this misconception that there was
luxuries that the main thing that you
think people I think they're gonna see a
side to my father they've never ever
seen hmm you know I see a lot of the ads
now saying you know that I go up against
him you know
carnot we have this conflict in this and
it was it was a very big conflict that
probably changed my life and could have
gone either way and you know I have to
give that man credit though he never
once looked me in the eye and said I
told you so hmm or and I remember one
day saying to him go ahead
you know you earned it go ahead and he
said I would never do that yeah so you
know which is something that I I felt
had to be told and told the right way
and this was it this is about him and I
and it was about him as a man at home
with me with his family but more how he
dealt with a lot of situations in my
life that shaped and molded Who I am
today or I would have never survived
half of what I what I have at all
he taught me you don't fall you bounce
you know and if you want to sit there
and give yourself a pity party go right
ahead you have five minutes and that was
it you know so now five minutes that's
it you can't move in no matter how you
feel you just keep getting out of that
bed and you just keep moving and keep
doing what you're doing and eventually
you'll be okay yeah I know for me and
for a lot of people talking about people
that we've lost is very difficult yeah
creating this film and telling your
father's story and also your story in
relation to him how does that affect
your grieving process does it make it
easier or does it do does it get more
complicated kind of bringing stuff up
does it bring stuff up for you it's
interesting you said that because I
never I well getting back to my going as
far back as my brother in 19 1980 yeah I
didn't have a chance to grieve I was
young 15 16 years old I didn't know
anything and I knew that something
tragic had happened in the house
obviously I had chores like every young
woman did and
I was going about my business when it
happened and then the next thing I knew
you know dad's telling me well you have
to know look after mama
you have to who she was catatonic I mean
for a long time we're not just talking
months I mean it was years and you have
to look after the house you have to like
after your younger brother who was
almost 4 you have to look you have to do
this you have to take care of that you
and it was like well there went my
social life there went school there went
my whole and I didn't understand what
was going on so I just kind of did what
I was told to do and years had gone by
yeah and I don't think I ever really
grieve properly for him or other people
that I lost around me and what I would
do is just be the person that was the
one you wanted to have around in that
emergency handle everything get it
handled take care of everybody else and
just keep it moving and doing this
sitting down writing this it was almost
like post-traumatic stress syndrome
where writing it I relived all of it in
my life from you know having my daughter
is still you know giving birth just to
hers are still born to my dad to other
things and it means you really go wait a
minute I can't believe this even happen
and you know you sit back for a minute
and then I had to actually leave that
computer and walk away for a couple of
days and digest it but I think it helped
me in that sense because my siblings
would always tell me you never wanted to
talk about our brothers you know passing
and that's not normal and I would always
say to them I just don't feel it's
something we should bring up you know
all the time and it's not a happy you
know occasion of my sister would always
say to me oh come on you leave the room
or you get teary-eyed and you just don't
participate and I just said to her I
don't I just don't want to hear about it
I don't want to relive it and she'd say
no you're avoiding it and I was and so I
think this forced me to confront my own
demons some of my own demons sitting
down writing it rereading it reliving it
and I think that was cathartic for me I
think that really helped me in a lot of
ways that I didn't think it would and
then watching it was like
Wow I mean I was crying through my own I
mean I wrote it and I should know what's
gonna happen and I saw the dailies but I
was crying through my own you know movie
and I was like why don't we shake this
off you know but you know
you